[Music]
[Applause]
here we are at lucky break charters in
Ocean City Maryland
we've got Ethan and the captain Jason
here and we're gonna go do some clamming
and crabbing and hopefully we'll get
lots of stuff and then we'll do some
catching and cooking video too as well
we could not ask for better weather it's
like 82 degrees Saturday and the
September absolutely beautiful hardly
believe it's fall daga are you excited
to go fishing do you like crab is it
it's like a giant spider that lives in
the ocean but is really tasty for me
nope
[Music]
like there could be a linear
[Music]
[Music]
Trudy taken India said there's cotton
there's crab pots have been so good
enough and the water would debate and
they're gonna pull up up we catch the
crab to the bottom
[Music]
all there's a writer
[Laughter]
big claw there you can pinch you can I
hold it yeah you gonna hold it back yeah
sure you wanna throw him back that's it
nice eyes boy right there yeah look at
that
my daddy oh there's some big ones in
there nice yep yeah put it in there and
you got the spots where the crabs go in
they dump down in there when you pull up
the trap
you relaxing MOBA yeah good careful tom
you know one of those crabs favorite
foods our fingers oh gosh she is it's
like wet toilet paper it's just he is so
soft you want to feel them grew it he
backed out he became soft backed out of
that she'll feel Oh soft is tell me it's
kind of got no claws
yeah headache how awful yeah we're
rolling out look great out I'd say you
grew about an inch the late quarter look
look at that like it lookout just I mean
you're just so cute
you're just a cuddly little guy so did
we put it with the others or will he
just get like gangrene
I get it these sheds his skin but the
fact that he sheds as long as that's
weird that's oh look how soft it is yeah
this is the softshell crabs claw it's
just it's just floppy look at that what
is that five inches congratulations you
wanna catch a fish yeah look who catch a
fish
[Music]
oh you're eating fish already right
you ready dig really can't finish
yeah well guys we're getting the whole
ocean fishing experience here we did
some crabbing now we're gonna go and
fish a little bit then we're gonna do
some clamming and get to try a little
bit of everything I call it a gumdrop
beat it's just a little soft piece of
meat
yeah it's right on these little hooks
perfect yeah that's nice then you got
got the nice natural bait but if you get
stripped off the hook you're not sure
you're still fishing yes we're gonna
fish two rods back in the shadow line
you can see the two shadows oh they're
all of the shadow line yeah don't mean
it took that out there are you guys your
first grunt
[Music]
oh yeah look at this these stingrays are
so much fun
there you go oh you got him look at you
guys you have a new species they're
holding it then it's a sea bass what you
get Oh a perch that's another fish for
you I think that's their first stand
perch buddy
you gonna oh there you go
then there's Sanford she is your first
in perch buddy I don't think you've ever
caught one
it's funny because stuff like this is so
much more fun for kids than any sort of
trophy fishing I mean the boys would
rather be doing this then reel it in 40
pound fish machine well guys we're here
for about an hour
landing about half a dozen fish in the
stingray I now we're gonna go hit the
clam so where you get a little the
sampling of everything what you've been
this your third day in the rain fishing
you're gonna start growing gills
[Music]
are you fine one clamp do about a 24
inch circle around that one spot a lot
of times clams will lay together they'll
be cluster as a clam now the real
question is how well the cold is the
water it's it's bracing somebody get a
break for me you can do it veca and it's
it get up like this oh it's a trophy one
here we go you know yeah you totally got
me I could feel like all this little
lake I just stepped on the crab if y'all
his legs he just pinched my toe there we
go now the boats moving up
there we go oh there's another one nice
if you have fun with that was that
awesome yeah did I tell you a crab fit
my foot I just like a little bruise
Jacob
those in your non-slip shoes those are
so cute
you're like a little baby monkey
Tommy what was your favorite part the
crabs
I like the fishing
we had an absolute ball on this trip if
you guys want to go out with lucky break
charters in Ocean City Maryland I'll put
a link down in the video description
check it out but we have a bunch of
crabs and clams to take home and so we
better get going get some ice on them
Nathan are you making dirt angels okay I
need to brush it off okay okay I'm
getting the sand off Oh pleasure that's
making I'm just getting the sand off all
right we're back home safe and sound and
I've got these crabs I've had them on
ice and we're gonna be making these for
dinner tomorrow night let's get them in
the refrigerator all right I've got a
steamer tray with some bonus crabs and
spicy sausage some potatoes then this
whole pot is jammed full of crabs
I've got corn on the cob slow roasting
in the oven I've got an apple Dutch oven
cobbler we're gonna make for dessert
I've got fried hush puppies tempo to the
shrimp coconut shrimp with a mango sauce
I've got apple butter I made myself a
fresh loaf of bread I'm not really
showing you guys how to make all this
stuff because I've done videos on all of
this if you want to see how to shell
crabs and cook crabs I'll put a link to
that video if you want to see how to
make the coconut shrimp I'll put a link
to that video you want to see how to
make the clams I'll put a link to that
video if you want to see how to make
bread I'll put a link to that video
[Music]
she doesn't know you guys want to see
that this soda yeah homemade carbonated
autumn all of the soda well hopefully
you guys enjoyed this video if you want
to see more great videos from the
outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to yeah if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like that and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching